in ancient times the god emperor of UT
was amongst the most powerful rulers in
all the known world the Empire was
prosperous with wealth that surpassed
even Valyria at its peak the vast empire
stretched from the bone mountains all
the way to the Jade Sea and was ruled by
the one true God on earth son of the
maiden of the light and the Lion of
night he was called the Emperor of the
dawn for ten thousand years he reigned
and for ten thousand years et prospered
according to the world of Ice and Fire
et is believed by some to be one of the
first places were mankind climbed out of
the pit of savagery and into
civilization et was one of the first
places to have towns and cities and also
one of the first to develop a system of
writing if legend can be believed the
wealth of UT was such that its princes
lived in houses of solid gold its cities
were grand spectacles larger than any
found in the West and he teased armies
were vast thought to be of nearly
unimaginable size et itself was a vast
Kingdom full of rolling hills deep Lakes
jungles and mighty forests all bound
together under the rule of the dawn
Emperor it is said that the Emperor of
the dawn wondered his kingdom in a
Polock and carved from a single giant
pearl hosts it up by his 100 Queens at
the end of his reign legend tells us
that the Emperor of the dawn ascended
into the stars leaving dominion of his
realm to his eldest son who was named
the Pearl Emperor during the millennia
that followed the dawn Emperor's death
each Emperor's reign was more troubled
and shorter than the last and according
to the world of Ice and Fire baleful
beasts pressed at the borders of their
empire ut became more chaotic as lesser
Kings grew prideful and rebellion rang
out through the lands it is said that
the people of ET had changed giving
themselves over to lust gluttony murder
and sloth at the height of these
troubles the amethyst Empress was slain
by her own brother who then called
himself the bloodstone Emperor
he usurped his sister and ushered in a
new era of Darkness but why
what corrupted ET to the point of
anarchy and kin slaying to find the
answer we have to dig deeper the world
of Ice and Fire tells us that the
bloodstone Emperor worship the black
stone that fell from the sky but it does
not in fact tell us when this black
stone arrived the stone could have very
well existed since the ascension of the
dawn Emperor the stone itself is clearly
a reference to the work of Lovecraft it
is otherworldly and is known to cause
terrifying dreams that can lead to
madness the black stone is mentioned
multiple times in our story including
but not limited to the sea stone chair
the monument of Toad Isle and the base
of the high tower at Old Town it would
seem that the arrival of the bloodstone
Emperor's stone correlates with the
descent of Yi T into chaos and darkness
it is known that during his reign the
bloodstone Emperor practiced many dark
arts including torture and necromancy
not unlike many still do in a shy until
this very day in fact the practices of
the bloodstone Emperor aligned well with
modern day practices and a shy ash I
itself is made entirely of the same
black stone and no magic is forbidden in
a shy even magic that requires the
extraction of human life so is there
something about the black stone that
causes people to become mad or perhaps
obsessed with dark magic beyond Yi T's
fabled five forts hiding in the frozen
gray wastes
waits the haunted city of Kadath it is
said that qaddafi is a place where
unspeakable rites are taking place all
in the name of ancient mad gods and
upriver through the heart of darkness
past a shy
lies the dark city of stag I were no man
dare venture boast a guy and Kadath are
loved craft references both our ancient
places where malevolent gods live it is
also common in Lovecraft's work for
sleeping or dormant gods such as Cthulhu
to send dreams into the minds of
humanity leading to chaos and sometimes
insanity
with all this considered the bloodstone
Emperor's black stone could possibly
mark the arrival of these deities the
baleful beasts mentioned earlier could
refer to these gods or their minions of
course so-called gods and Lovecraftian
lore are really just supreme beings far
surpassing the intelligence of people
humans are inconsequential to them and
merely tolerated I would argue that
there is evidence that such beings exist
in martens universe as well although
they are far more abstract affecting the
world only through suggestion was the
bloodstone Emperor corrupted by such
beings it is believed by many and Yi T
that the bloodstone Emperor's actions
led directly to the event which is now
known as the long night a period of time
where darkness ruled for generation the
world of Ice and Fire also counts the
bloodstone Emperor as the first high
priest of the starry wisdom a nefarious
cult the name is again borrowed directly
from Lovecraft in his lore the Church of
the starry wisdom worships Nyarlathotep
also known as the chaos King so we have
a mysterious insidious black stone a
malevolent old city hiding in a frozen
desert and a baleful cult that worships
a god of chaos all of which would be
expected if Lovecraftian type entities
were present in the isang of Ice and
Fire universe and since it was the
bloodstone Emperor's worship of the
black stone and his other dark practices
that were believed to have brought about
the long night does that mean that it
was the will of these so-called gods
there are multiple places in A Song of
Ice and Fire where these entities seem
likely to reside including Stagg I and
the heart of winter as I discussed in my
video on ash I Kadath is another which
makes even more sense considering its
proximity to ET could the being at Kedah
have been responsible for the fall of
the dawn Empire and perhaps even the
long night itself
if so then why
well beings of chaos hold the name for a
reason they are a source of fear and
dread in humans and cause anxiety and
mistrust amongst mankind the people of
ET hold that the world was a broken
place after the long night
to quote the world of ice and fire
directly yet the great Empire of the
dawn was not reborn for the restored
world was a broken place where every
tribe of men when its own way fearful of
all the others and war and lust and
murder endured even to our present day
or so the men and women of the further
east believed
modernity is a grand kingdom of ruins
were a hundred Prince's and three
emperors can test for power all ruling
as they please within their own domains
and so UT the once great single Empire
is now divided and chaotic was it the
simple natural course of entropy or was
it the will of nefarious beings from
beyond the stars to take no mind to the
lesser beings that get in the way of
their sport there is no actual way to
know for sure
these events are some of the oldest in
the history of the world bison fire ET
was old before men ever ventured west
all we can say for sure is that Martin
has made very clear references to H P
Lovecraft's mythos especially in regards
to the black stone madness and chaotic
gods but we will likely never know for
certain thank you guys for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
ideas of Ice and Fire